A rumored affair, a violent assault,
and some serious allegations. Did Netflix's
new Marilyn Monroe feature go too far?
Netflix's "Blonde," which is based on Joyce Carol
Oates' novel of the same name, and stars Ana de
Armas as Marilyn Monroe, has been creating a lot
of controversy. Despite being a work of fiction,
"Blonde" has shocked audiences, because it draws
inspiration from one of Hollywood's most iconic
figures, and as it received an NC-17 rating,
meaning that it contains several shocking scenes.
The fictionalized account of Monroe's life
explores the possible trauma, failures,
successes, and intense pressure the "Some Like It
Hot" star might have faced throughout her life.
Viewers are given an imagined behind-the-scenes
look at what the world's most famous stars face,
examining the human being inside
the gilded veneer of the myth.
While it's true that some people
want nothing more than to be famous,
others come to rue such a bright spotlight.
Since "Blonde" draws inspiration from the life
of a historical figure, several other
real-life people associated with the
star also feature in the fictional
account. However, not everyone is
shown in a flattering light. Discussing the
film's NC-17 rating, de Armas told Empire,
"It's a film that is supposed to
create controversy and discomfort,
and it's supposed to make you
think about what happened — and
what is still happening [...] It's
revolutionary, and I think it's so brave."
The actor also pointed out that
although "Blonde" is rated NC-17,
she doesn't consider the movie's
content particularly gratuitous, saying,
"Despite the NC-17 rating, I never felt that
there was anything exploitative [...] This
movie is meant to be an experience,
to move along with her feelings,
what she's going through. And that,
unfortunately, takes what it takes."
However, it quickly became clear that "Blonde"
features one especially gut-wrenching scene
that's harrowing and deeply uncomfortable for
both viewers and history aficionados alike.
According to The Daily Beast, this particular
scene in "Blonde" focuses on Marilyn Monroe and
John F. Kennedy, played by Caspar Phillipson.
The moment begins with Monroe being picked up
by secret service agents from an airplane in
New York City. The actress is then dragged
through a hotel and presented to Kennedy,
and that's when the story becomes shocking.
"I'm not a child. You don't
have to worry about me."
In Netflix's fictional account, Kennedy
sexually assaults Monroe multiple times,
which is understandably difficult for audiences
to watch. In the movie, when Monroe wakes up,
she is bloody and bruised. However,
presidential historians will likely
take exception with how the alleged
relationship between the president
and the film star has been presented.
Obviously, it has long been rumored that
the real-life Kennedy and Monroe had some kind
of relationship with one another. For instance,
Frank Sinatra's friend Tony Oppedisano opened up
to People about the possible connection, alleging,
"It was obviously a sexual thing, and I would
expect that there were feelings on her side.
Just taking a look at the footage of her
singing her 'Happy Birthday,' that speaks
for itself. [...] She respected him; she admired
him. She loved what he was doing with the country,
and then to have a physical relationship with
him, she found him attractive and vice versa."
However, not everyone agrees that Monroe and
Kennedy were actually engaged in any sort of
illicit affair. As a result, many historians
will likely find fault with Netflix's "Blonde,"
and the devastating suggestion that Monroe
was assaulted by the president. However,
it's crucial to remember that the
new film is based upon a novel,
and not a biography. Whether or not
Kennedy and Monroe were romantically
linked in real life, "Blonde" continues to
shock viewers due to its explicit content.
If you or anyone you know has
been a victim of sexual assault,
help is available. Visit the Rape,
Abuse & Incest National Network
website or contact RAINN's National
Helpline at 1-800-656-HOPE (4673).